[Music]
in this problem a water pollution
control plant or
wpcp takes daily measurements of a given
pollutant to ensure compliance with
their npdes permit the permit states
that the weekly geometric mean of the
pollutant shall not exceed 25 mg per
liter the pollutant measurements for a
given pollutant are recorded in the
following
table on Tuesday the table was not up
updated after taking the measurement the
monitoring system provided the geometric
mean at the end of the week to be 20 MGS
per liter what is the maximum value that
Tuesday's measurement could have been so
as not to violate the npdes
permit so this is a simple math problem
disguised as an environmental
engineering or Water Resources problem
in the reference manual we can simply
search for geometric mean to find the
equation that we need in chapter
1 so the geometric mean equation is
written as
follows X1 X2
X3 up to x to the n
all to the square root of
n so there is one small trick in this
problem worth pointing out in case it
isn't apparent the problem provides you
with the geometric mean calculated at
the end of the week but then it asks
what the max value could have been on
the missing day which would have not
exceeded the NPD
standard so we can fill out the equation
with our known as
follows the geometric mean set by the
nip permit is 25 Mig per
[Music]
liter and our X terms can simply be the
days of the week for which we have
data so we have
7.81 I'm going to ignore units in this
problem as they're all
consistent times
7.81
time X on
Tuesday time
6387 *
24.84 *
7.10 *
24.84 and all of these are going to be
square rooted by the same number of
terms here which is going to be seven
days
then we can rearrange to solve for the
missing day's Max possible value that
would cause it to not exceed this
standard so simplifying this down we can
move our terms around to isolate for X
as
follows *
7.81 *
6387 so with X on one side the geometric
mean is going to be in the numerator
position and the remaining days of the
week are going to be in the
denominator 1 2 3 4 5 six okay
and solving for x we can find that x = 3
57.6 millgram per
liter and our closest answer over here
is going to be
360 now this answer may seem high but
that is the point of the geometric mean
outlier values are less
significant it's also why solving for a
geometric mean of 20 and correctly
instead of 25 will give you a noticeably
different answer so avoid this trick by
reading the problem carefully and you
will solve this problem
correctly and that's
it